well the immediate response force from
the Army's 82nd Airborne Division has
now been deployed to the region in case
Iran does retaliate David Martin is at
the Pentagon with more on this story
David all of this is so alarming so how
urgent is the situation do you think
well both sides are making threats and
both sides have increased the alert
level of their forces including in
Iran's case their ballistic missiles so
it's a recipe for miscalculation
but the administration insists is not
having any second thoughts about killing
sulamani when it had the chance we made
the right decision to take out this
terrorists Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo watched the Thursday night strike
at the Pentagon along with defense
secretary mark Esper and Joint Chiefs
chairman mark millions and he is now the
administration's chief spokesman
defending it appearing on all the sunday
talk shows he not only caused enormous
death and destruction throughout the
region killed hundreds of Americans over
the years but had done so in the past
couple of days CBS News has learned some
military commanders were not in favor of
killing sulamani on the grounds Iran
would feel compelled by its national
honor to strike back making the war
nobody wants more likely Democrats are
making a similar argument we do not
generally execute high-level political
figures of sovereign nations in part
because we know that that opens a
Pandora's box that may expose American
officials to assassination but also
because we know that ultimately that
might get more Americans killed the US
has more than enough firepower both at
sea and at air bases to make good on
president Trump's threat to strike 52
targets including Iranian cultural sites
this is bigger than bin Laden it's
bigger than Baghdadi this is the the
equivalent in u.s. terms of the CIA
director CENTCOM commander JSOC
commander and presidential envoy for the
region for Iran but former CIA director
and Mideast commander David Petraeus
says the US needs a plan to decrease
tensions will there be a diplomatic
initiative that says okay look this is
not headed
in a good direction we truly do want to
de-escalate everyone is going to lose if
this continues to ratchet up word
according to the Defense Intelligence
Agency Iran has the largest missile
force in the Middle East enough to
launch salvos across the Persian Gulf to
bases where US aircraft are located but
Iranian missiles are not considered very
accurate and the US has Patriot air
defense missiles capable of shooting
them down Anthony David thank you
you